he's the CEO of LinkedIn in 2011 he and
Reid Hoffman were the ernst & young
entrepreneurs of the year us overall
winners in 2014 he was recognized as one
of the top 10 CEOs at US tech companies
he's Jeff Weiner and here his top 10
rules for success because if you're a
true visionary you're gonna be seen
something that other people don't see or
feel threatened by because it's going to
potentially disrupt the way that they've
always done things you have to believe
in what you're doing you have to believe
in your vision with truly every fiber of
your being and that conviction provides
the courage to other people to pursue
the same and if you don't feel it if you
are just going through the motions if
you're using somebody else's words
people will will sense that from a mile
away right they need and want to pursue
authentic leadership first of all it's a
very human thing to project your own
perspective on to others it's a very
think common thing and as a less
experienced executive or a leader or for
anyone in the audience that works with
other people the tendency will be to
expect people to do things the way you
do them yeah it's very natural and it's
it's not the right way to approach it
you need to take a moment to manage
compassionately put yourself in their
shoes understand why they're coming with
what they come with what is their
background what is their baggage where
are their anxieties what inspires them
where are their strengths their
weaknesses and that takes time and it
takes real investment in the knee-jerk
reaction is just to do things the way
you would normally do them and that's
going to create a lot of dissonance and
so from that moment going forward I kind
of decided that would be a first
principle of management be managing
compassionately first and foremost is
asking yourself a pretty straightforward
question sometimes a little more
challenging to answer which is
ultimately what is it that you want to
accomplish so look out 20 to 30 years
from now looking back on your career
what you want to say you did and I think
when you're graduating school it's it's
perfectly reasonable to not necessarily
know the answer but you'd be surprised
how many people 10 15 years into their
career
still not know the answer the question
because they get swept up in the stream
of opportunity you know a promotion here
and offer from a hot company over there
and they wake up one day and they're not
happy and they're trying to figure out
why it's because they never stopped to
ask themselves what it is that they
ultimately want and if you don't know
the answer to that question try
optimizing for two things one is passion
and the other skill and it's not one at
the exclusion of the other
because that will lead to some pretty
suboptimal outcomes so that's one know
what it is that you want to accomplish
as simple as it sounds it's really
really important to is surround yourself
with great people I used to think this
was all about finding the right boss or
the right mentor but it's not just about
the person above you it's about the
people you work with your peers and the
people that work for you
it's all about talent in this day and
age and so you have to surround yourself
with the best only the best and then
third is to always be learning and to
take great passion if you can in
improving yourself and to challenge
yourself it's all about the conversation
and it's very rarely if ever about
actually selling and as soon as someone
comes in to see me and they open up a
PowerPoint presentation they've
essentially lost me I think most
effective interactions of this sort
start with you know first of all some
ice break and getting to know the other
person but then a simple question which
is what can I help you with you know
what what are your objectives what are
your priorities
what are you trying to solve for and
then determining how in this case if
we're on the selling end how LinkedIn
can benefit your organization and really
make it a conversation and I think that
makes all the difference in the world
just starting from there similarly you
know I feel all too often people have a
tendency this is kind of classic public
speaking effective public speaking but
you got to know your audience and it's
not necessarily about what you know and
what you want to present it's about what
your audience wants to hear and why
they're there you know they're taking
time out of their schedule to be there
why have they come to the meeting what
are they hoping to get out of it and as
tempted as we're all going to be to
stick to the material that we've
prepared that's really for our benefit
and perhaps we're going to end up using
some of that because it's relevant for
the audience but I think it's really
important to understand what it is that
the folks are trying to connect with
what what they're trying to learn more
about and and how we can benefit them I
think one of the things that all really
strong leaders have is extraordinary
awareness and what I've noticed is these
individuals have the ability to read and
take the pulse of a room whether it's
talking to one individual their staffs
of 10 or 12 people or a group of 1,800
and to be able in real-time while
expressing themselves and while
communicating and while thinking to be
able to take in what's happening yeah
and that awareness enables them to
course-correct hmm and that is such an
important part of leadership is that
course-correction
in every moment ideally I don't know
that people always have that luxury but
moment to moment our to our day to day
courted a quarter year to year it's
being able to understand your
environment the competitive landscape
the technical landscape the talent
landscape the people you're working with
what motivates them and to be able to
course-correct
and that starts with awareness so I
couldn't agree more in that first man
why join LinkedIn was the ability to
make a difference in the world in a very
positive way you look at the platform
you look at the vision about creating
economic opportunity I can't think of a
more worthwhile purpose than investing
in tools that create economic
opportunity for people there there's no
more sustainable or profound way to
change the quality of an individual's
life in my opinion than creating an
economic opportunity for them and in
turn improving the quality of the life's
of their family the lives of the people
that they can create economic
opportunity for and in developing
countries you're creating role models
for the next generation that didn't even
know it was possible and that's pretty
appealing to be able to make a
difference and it starts by asking
yourself the question what would it take
to make that dream or that vision
statement of reality
and that question what would it take
it's incredibly powerful and liberating
and if you set your sights too low
sometimes you'll never challenge
yourself to think bigger sometimes
you'll never challenge yourself to
question conventional wisdom but by
asking the question what would it take
it unleashes all of this creative energy
and it unleashes the sense that anything
is possible and so we started asking
ourselves the question what would it
take to make the vision a reality what
would it take to not just connect the
world's professionals 780 million people
but create economic opportunity for over
3 billion people in the global world you
know I personally believe that
leadership is about the ability to
inspire others to achieve shared
objectives and I think the most
important word there is inspire and I
think that's what separates leaders from
managers managers tell people what to do
and leaders inspire them to do it and I
think inspiration largely emanates
emanates from three dimensions the first
is the clarity of your vision and what
mountain you're trying to summit and
climb and the second is the courage of
your conviction because if you have true
vision and you want to try something
that hasn't been done before there's
going to be a lot of naysayers there's
going to be a lot of skeptics there's
going to be a lot of people who feel
threatened and try to get in your way
and you have to feel it deeply to be
able to overcome those challenges and
for people to want to follow you and if
you're not authentic in that belief and
you don't have true conviction they're
not going to be behind you and then
lastly is the ability to effectively
communicate that vision and that
conviction and I think if leaders are in
a position where they can do those three
things that they can effectively inspire
and when you can inspire it's just a
matter of what objective you're trying
to achieve and then ensuring that you're
surrounding yourself with the absolute
best talent you can to make it a reality
while you're in the moment
someone's doing something that upsets
you were frustrates you we all have a
natural tendency to become very
emotional and part of managing
compassionately is having the
wherewithal to be a spectator to your
own thoughts especially when you become
emotional and get a little bit of that
distance and enables you to put yourself
in their shoes and ask yourself why are
they behaving the way that they're
behaving there's a wisdom potentially or
a rightness to how they're behaving or
it could be a wisdom it could be in your
parlance a rightness it could be a
wrongness but they're not to be blamed
for the wrongness yeah they're it's not
a blame game if they're angry at you
maybe they're angry by virtue of
something that took place years ago had
nothing to do with you
and when that anger comes your way the
knee-jerk is going to be to become angry
in response now they're angry and you're
angry and guess what happens I mean
every single one of us has been in that
situation probably every day I was just
someone just wrote me an email the other
day and they were angry about something
and I need jerked and I was frustrated
if not outright angry that they were
expressing themselves like that and then
I took a minute before I responded
thought to myself I wonder why there's
no emotional about this and what can we
do about it and I ended up get on the
phone with them and I said are you
trying to solve a problem or are you
just trying to vent mm-hmm so I'd like
to solve this problem and I think it's
too late and as a result I'm very angry
I said it's never too late let's focus
on solving the problem and then after
that let's come back to how you
expressed yourself my advice would be
don't just optimize for passion you have
to optimize from both passion and skill
and for the entrepreneur without a third
dimension which is the market and if you
can find the convergence the Nexus of
those three elements your passion your
skill and the market and you've got the
right timing of course you know anything
is possible and and for me it's all
about knowing what it is you ultimately
want to accomplish thank you guys so
much for watching I made this video
because Jason Bruton asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur then you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of Jeff
weiners top 10 rules you like the best
and most resonated with you leaving the
comments below I'm going to join in the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon